why was this the perfect outfit this
evening um because i'm actually gonna be
walking in the blonde show which is like
in an hour so i was at the fitting
yesterday and i was like i need
something for the vmas
this is perfect it truly is
paris full and double duty as usual i
love it always have you heard the good
news that's buzzing around the carpet
this evening your friend britney spears
is engaged yes oh my god i didn't hear
that yet you hadn't heard no i haven't
even looked at my i had my engagement
dinner and party last night so
yeah just been doing a lot of that but
that makes me so happy and
i just wish her all the love and
happiness in the world because she
deserves it she certainly does well
you've been doing a lot of leg work for
your upcoming nuptials so i guess now
that you're both brides to be maybe you
can share some of the work with her
right good idea yes i need all the help
i can get are you looking forward to
telling brittany the next time you chat
with her
just how happy i am for her and how
proud i am for her using her voice and
standing up for herself and
really just turning her pain into a
purpose and
i just really feel that she deserves her
happiness and freedom more than anyone
it's been really beautiful to see your
support for your longtime friend you
know so
you know
it's important to be there for the good
times and the bad times always there for
my friends yeah okay is it nice to see
the barclays lit up like this for vmas
again i know you are no stranger to this
scene young lady i love it it's so much
fun my friend kim petrus asked me to
come and we rode up together in this
like little pink car it was so cute of
course you did why did you feel that
because you and kim hit a party earlier
this week that you dj'd she performed
why did you want to take kim under your
wing
i love her i think she's incredible i
did her first music video with her and
just seeing her grow and blossom and i
think she's such an inspiration and icon
and she reminds me of like the next
madonna oh
that is a bold statement yes well have
fun so now like congrats on having your
engagement party left thank you